- I'm a huge Marvel fan,
I love superhero stuff.
I mean, Eternals is huge.
Being a part of the
Marvel Universe is huge.
Are you so stoked?
(audience cheers)
- Yes.
I don't think
I like,
I've been getting the
dosages of how big it is
little by little, like
the premier there were,
I just arrive at the red carpet,
and I started seeing all
these people dressed as us.
The movie's not out yet,
and then
Kelly I saw this family, this,
the father and the mother was dressed,
they were Latinos as Ajak and
the three little daughters
also like Ajak and they
made their own costumes
and all these girls,
Latino girls were Ajak.
- I love that!
- I wanted to cry.
- That's really cool.
- I wanted to cry and then I
had to do all the interviews,
but it really warmed my heart, you know,
because there is
somebody that you can identify with.
- [Kelly] Yeah no inclusion like,
and a little kid seeing
someone that looks like them
that can be, they dream bigger.
That's totally a thing, I
agree, and I think it's awesome.
I think that they are showing more.
This is a diverse cast and
they're showing more diversity.
I think that's important,
especially when it comes to superheroes,
because we hold them so high for children.
You know, like they're always
dressing up as Halloween.
There are all the stories
about them saving the day.
It's like, they need
to look like everyone.
(audience claps)
- Wait a minute, I just saw
myself on TV and it's crooked.
- [Kelly] You loosening up?
- Sorry, but the brilliant part is that
being superheroes who were
actually not from earth.
- Yeah, I know, I love it.
- So it's not about your diversity,
I think it's in this movie it reminds you,
it's not really even
about where you come from.
It's only celebrating
the difference between us
and what's inside of you
that makes you diverse.
That it's like, what you're made of.
That is what is important
for this amazing story.
Not just the geographical point.
- [Kelly] And not just the aesthetics.
- It's not the aesthetics because
I'm not a Mexican and I'm not from Earth,
but it's everything about Mexico that
there is a lot to give as a Mexican person
just in your blood, how you grew up,
and it's almost like your
energy of what it is,
your whole history that is valued,
not necessarily the geographical point.
- Yeah, I love that.
I'm so excited.
So wait, what was it like in your costume?
Was it miserable or was it awesome?
Did you feel superhero?
- This show is going to give me a bad rep
because now I'm talking about
all my psychological problems.
I don't know how we landed.
I'm also claustrophobic.
- Oh my gosh.
- Stage fright, claustrophobic, and so
I was terrified of the suit.
- Oh.
- I was terrified to get in the suit
and how I was going to be
able to move or not move
and I was I going to get claustrophobic,
because, you know, sometimes
when I get claustrophobic,
the first thing is I want
to take the clothes off.
Actually, I actually did it once.
I didn't take it completely,
but I started unzipping myself
in the middle of a movie
because I had to do a scene
on stage with all the people,
and I started getting,
and I started, and then what is she doing?
She's taking it off.
I said, I won't take it all off.
I just need to breathe,
because I was really
tight in that corset dress
and it was just a scene in a movie
and it just brought it up.
So I was terrified that I
was going to be the superhero
that went crazy and started stripping
in the middle of a scene.
I don't take it all off, I
just need room to breathe.
- I just want to thank you
for making me feel normal.
(laughing)
(audience clapping)
The fact that you like
are kinda like that,
and you seem super normal.
- We're soul mates, you and I.
- I'm like I love it.
- But it's normal to have
little things here and there,
right guys?
- Yes!
Salma, and awesome,
weird people are the best anyway.
That's what I say.
- [Salma] Perfect is not normal.
- [Kelly] Yes, they're liars.
- Screw them.
- [Kelly] Yeah.